من جهاتها قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
وحداتها صدت محاولات نوكرانيه لتعزيز
مواقع تمركزها في منطقه تياف ديفكا
ومارينكا فيدونيس وان انظمه الدفاع الجوي
وسلاح الجو الروسيين تمكنا من اسقاط عشر
مسيرات ومروحيه اوكرانيه فوق دونتس ولوجان
بدله القوات المسلحه
الشعبيه ونتيجه للاستهداف المباشر والمكثف
قتل حوالي 60 جنديا اوكرانيا وتم تدمير
دبابتين وخمس مركبات قتاليه وفي اتجاه
جنوب قام العدو بمحاولات الهجوم المضاد في
ثلاث مناطق في جمهوريه الشعبيه لكن
الضربات الجويه الهجوميه
اوقفت الهجمات الاوكرانيه واعاده
المهاجمين الى مواقع الاصليه وبلغت خسائر
العدو في هذا الاتجاه اكثر من 40 قتيلا
وجريحا اوكرانيا وفي كوبيان دمر الطيران
العمليات والتكيكي ثلاثه مواقع قياده
للعدو واربع 74 واحده